We can also use public key cryptography
for mutual authentication.
Suppose Alice and
Bob have each other's public key.
In this protocol, first,
Alice sends Bob a challenge R2 and
R2 is encrypted using Bob's public key.
Second, upon receiving this challenge
Bob decrypts the server text
using his own public key, and
sends back the plain text challenge R2,
along with his own challenge R1.
And R1 is encrypted using
Alice's public key.
Third, when Alice gets the response
from Bob, the plain text R2 in
Bob's response, tells Alice that she's
communicating with Bob because only Bob
has the private key that is paired
with the public key that encrypted R2.
Alice also decrypts the server text
R1 using her own private key and
sends a plain text back
to Bob in step three.
Bob will then know that he is
communicating with Alice because only
Alice has the private key that is paired
with the public key used to encrypt R1.
As an exercise,
you can modify this protocol
to use signing with private keys
instead of encryption with public keys.